en 2018 les nations unies avaient sacré
emmanuel macron champions de la terre un
peu et l'équivalent du prix nobel de la
paix mais version écologique difficile à
entendre pour les associations
environnementales qui dénonce une
trahison démocratique car si le
président de la république a fait bonne
figure à l'international le fossé entre
les promesses et la réalité est bien là
selon les ong de défense de
l'environnement le projet de loi climat
n'est pas aboutie et ne répond pas aux
enjeux climatiques
ce projet de loi ne permettra pas à la
france d'atteindre ses objectifs de
réduction de ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre on voit pourtant les
impacts du réchauffement climatique tous
les jours on ne comprend pas que le
gouvernement et les parlementaires ne
réalisent pas que nous sommes face à un
péril imminent selon greenpeace le bilan
du chef de l'état est catastrophique
mais la majorité présidentielle estime
défendre un projet ambitieux équilibré
et qui aboutira à un changement de
société
la loi climat résilience est un texte
riche et concret à l'origine de
changements majeurs pour notre société
et créatrice de solutions pratiques pour
les français une loi qui fera entrer
l'écologie dans nos vies selon mélanie
blanche aux membres de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat le rôle des
lobbys est important on constate qu'il
ya énormément de blocage sur ces
questions depuis 30 ans avec des lobbys
qui met sans cesse en avant les pertes
d'emplois liées à certaines mesures
sans parler des créations d'emplois que
ces mêmes mesure impliquerait quelques
exemples en 2010 est le chef de l'état
avait promis d'interdire le glyphosate
il n'a pas réussi
emmanuel macron a reconnu un échec
collectif pointant du doigt l'europe
prenez un autre exemple les
néonicotinoïdes ces insecticides tueur
d'abeilles
ils ont été interdits en 2018 avant
d'être partiellement autorisé à nouveau
deux ans plus tard
ensuite le chef de l'état voulait
interdire toute nouvelle attribution des
permis d'exploration d'hydrocarbures
avec la loi hulot en 2017
malgré le texte les prolongations des
concessions sont déjà accordé jusqu'en
autre exemple emmanuel macron avait
promis la fermeture de toutes les usines
à charbon françaises d'ici 2022
pourtant la centrale à charbon de
cordemais
continuera à fonctionner au moins
jusqu'en 2024 et enfin la france n'a pas
réussi à tenir ses objectifs de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre néanmoins deux textes ont
marqué le mandat macron la loi
d'orientation des mobilités et la loi
anti gaspillage
mais face à de nombreux enjeux
climatiques ce n'est pas assez pour les
associations environnementales
l'exécutif français a donc encore du
pain sur la planche en février dernier
l'état a été condamné par le tribunal
administratif de paris est reconnu
responsable d'une action climatique
une première en france